I am in Tromso in Norway in the Arctic
Circle and this beautiful thing here is
one of the boats that plies the
Hurtigruten
and I am probably mispronouncing that
but the fast route from down in the
southwest of Norway all the way up to
here in the Arctic Circle
I say fast route it takes seven days but
here is something you might not know
this is an excellent example of slow
television something that the NRK the
national broadcaster the equivalent of
the BBC or PBS excels at in 2011 they
took a load of cameras and just attach
them to this boat and broadcast its
journey 24 hours a day as it went up
well not specifically this boat one very
much like it also because they did in
the middle of summer and it was not a
freezing cold mid-afternoon it's about
2:30 as I record this it was beautiful
all the way Norwegian fjords gorgeous so
well if you want to see it fortunately
they released all the footage through
Creative Commons so there's some
interesting mashups here on YouTube if
you don't await the full 134 hours but
people did here's the strange thing
people did watch this maybe just for a
few minutes maybe for a few hours maybe
they just kept it on the television all
the time in the same way as they kept on
the train that stayed for 24 hours
through Norway or the log fire that
simply burned slow television is an
antidote to the reality TV show and the
first cut editing of today and is it
massively popular well no of course not
that's why you're watching 2 minute
videos on YouTube rather than 134 hours
of footage of a boat but don't rule it
out because it's surprising that how
many people will just tune in for a
little while to something calming and
pleasant and slow and that is something
you might not have known
you